a special guest in studio that's right
we have a Bobby Patel who is the chair
of strategy across the board a gala to
support the Hall of Fame and the Chess
Club and he is with Maurice yes a big
Patel
we always like it to see corporate execs
come in and help the Chess Club help to
make this wonderful work that they do
even more wonderful and I got to say
he's the most relaxed looking lawyer
I've never seen he's coming with all
smiles I think welcome to the show
how did you get involved in being a part
of this magic here at the Chess Club now
I appreciate being here and thanks for
having me I got involved last year
actually was part of the committee that
put the gala on last year really enjoyed
it is a great event that got my kids
involved with the Hall of Fame chess
club and getting lessons from
grandmasters and they just took it they
just took it maybe they ran weather they
absolutely love the game so did your
kids make you chair it this year they
said daddy you got to take over this
time actually the club did a pretty good
job instead of issac me to come out here
they give us so much access to so many
great things and the grandmasters that
teach our kids how to play chess and
it's just it's just been so much fun
it's hard to pass up from last year was
indeed a wonderful one we see look I was
speaking at the events as well but all
those great kids who come out speak to
why it is that chess is so important for
young people I think it teaches
discipline and it teaches foresight and
strategy and think through your actions
and and I think those are all things
that are developmental tools for your
children they become young adults and be
a contributor to the society absolutely
just beautiful shots last year and we
advise everyone to certainly help out as
you can speaking of your kids your
family together plays chess now they do
who's who's the best trash talker in the
family
Oh trash talker is my youngest JN who's
at 6 years old and he's the best trash
talker of all of us he's not the best
chess player I was wondering
not quite there but I think eventually
he'll take us all we gotta take the
Brooklyn because we don't figure too
much trash talk right and certainly can
help out chess chess in law I always put
people on the spot with this one their
profession and the game how do they
relate both are completely about
strategy I mean if you think about it
when we try to get when we try to help
our clients legally either through a
litigation or some kind of lawsuit or
some transaction we're looking at
several moves from the beginning to the
end and misfires along the way you're
gonna lose the game right and so what is
chess same thing it's a series of moves
based on overarching principles and
strategy that helps you win the game and
they're so similar and it sounds like
you've been taking lessons yeah I think
my kids are teaching me anything else
yeah we come here from time to time and
we the whole family me and my two boys
actually we we take some lessons with
some grandmasters and it's been great no
I just got in there oh I'm just
naturally gifted that's why I talk like
that no no you got grandmaster help
coming absolutely well it's a wonderful
event what details should people know
about the event that's going to happen
this year so the events just a really
fun relaxed event that really encourages
the passion for chess to get further
it's a great event because it's the
fundraising that helps with our
scholastics opportunities as well as the
exhibition and everything else at the
Hall of Fame and if you just have a
passion you should just come out there
it's great you get to see some great
players you get to see some of the kids
that the fundraising helps out with and
it's just a really fun event we see
their December 14th it will occur just
go to st. Louis chess club dot org for
more information so I was like it's in
good hands but V Patel thank you so much
for what you do and look forward to
seeing you at the event thanks a lot
thanks for